when Stefani takes her sons and a  boyfriend to Blake Shelton on a tour of  her hometown  back when the 47 year old rock star was  just a girl she lived here in Anaheim  California how weird to be at the Beacon  Street house right now back to your  crappy school one gave her man and her  kids a glimpse of her Orange County  upbringing Wednesday documenting all the  nostalgia on snapchat what do you think  that's it there's my house I grew up in  the cute that's my bedroom over there  he's hit earlier in the day the group  had a magical time at yet another  Anaheim hot spot Disneyland when was  clearly feeling the Halloween spirit she  posed with Donald Duck dressed like a  pumpkin wearing her orange and black  females ears  you